thank you
[Music]
so Tyler as somebody from the LGBT
community how do you feel about the
boycotts going on against Bud Light
Target Lionheart Jiu Jitsu just all of
them
how do you feel about it
honestly can we boycott more cheap beers
you get it for cheaper these are way
better in the first place yeah like when
I drink water I think it's overpriced I
don't know
lower calorie what was the whole boycott
about was it kind of like a misalignment
of demographic like Bud Light was trying
to like expand because I always thought
like I think Bud Light was for like the
get off my [__] property I think
everybody thought that but I think what
they were trying to do was be inclusive
and include another group that they
normally they're trying to expand their
market share yeah but then you alienate
but they alienate their core yeah the
aliators the story is about the the
trans girl who had her face like put on
the Bud Light right and that's how
people are mad yeah Dylan Mulvaney
something Delaney Dylan wolvenia there's
another one that recently was it not Bud
Light a Miller Lite North Face too yeah
really what'd they do they did uh um it
was like uh something about like about
coming out but then it was like in the
forest
and I didn't I didn't watch the whole
thing but um I did see that like people
were mad I mean if it's for pride month
you have all these corporations that
already have their rollouts ready to go
for like their ads yeah so it's kind of
like you are going to see them but what
was the the JK news LGBT roll out for
the month we just had five minutes with
Nick's face just like
just different positions I mean you know
Pander to either demographic
think of YouTube people have called us
gay so like I mean come on dude like do
we even have to come out at this point
they've been calling us gay since the
beginning it's pretty clear but when you
do you feel like are you ever pressured
to also speak out or anything like that
to be or to take a Firm Stance or be
against it I've never been like
politically aligned with my sexuality
before like it's not
I feel like I'm too young to be I have
to do that I don't know just doesn't
seem
I guess I would say something if like
something personally affected me yeah
like I remember whenever I was in high
school making like a Facebook post like
saying oh we should like like it should
be legalized Like Love Is Love and
everything and that was like a pretty
like pretty big stance like 10 years ago
or whatever yeah but since it's been
legalized like there's politically at
all yeah I don't I honestly I think with
all these like giant companies try to do
the Pander like I'm not it doesn't hit
me as a demographic like they don't hit
me the right way does it make you go oh
I should go buy some fun light right now
from your Rainbow I don't think rainbow
looks good on clothes personally
I don't still think it's it's clashing
yeah I think it's actually very funny
as says gays are supposed to be like
well dressed and makes like no sense to
me that rainbow is like the fashion
it's fair fair like I think black should
be I think black's a bit more appealing
a black flag
that's like piracy that's actually
pretty tight it's like militant dude we
found it the JK LGBT rollout is we're
making a new LGBT flag
[Laughter]
so it's like different shades of black
girls hair the police one grayscale
actually that's the greatest video with
the blue line with the grayscale though
when I was in school I think we called
kids who listen to Black Flag gay so it
kind of fits kind of works out it isn't
it isn't it crazy though like we've
witnessed the social acceptance of like
the gay community into the mainstream
like we've seen it because I remember as
early as uh or as late as like high
school there would be news about a gay
couple walking down the street and
getting beat up yeah or like like I
think they killed a guy happy Shepherd
yeah yeah walking around holding hands
and then some guys jumped out and and
then this was in LA or this was in
Hollywood like in the gay community guys
would go into West Hollywood to bash
some gay dudes and stuff if you do that
you're just gay yourself and mad that
other people are probably dating the
dude you want to do that's projective
right why else would you want to beat up
a game like exactly and that's what I
always thought it's about you you come
from it has to come from somewhere yeah
true dude I assure you they're not mad
about some people they don't care about
doing something they they care for some
reason because straight great men should
be more like happy when there's a lot of
good looking guys that are your
competition that's going out with other
good-looking guys and then now you're
just like hey I just now brought myself
from being a six to an eight in the uh
in the woman's eyes
it's all a game of relativity
dude plus in those in the countries like
that have problems right now where
there's more [__] chicks than dudes
yeah dude some of those dudes better be
like oh my God the gay community please
you gotta rise up over here too
you know what I mean like dudes can't
even get laid out there yeah that's true
you need a gay community yeah in China
yeah yeah there's more guys than girls
in China China's got to keep their
Community super underground they do yeah
yeah like out of necessity for your life
yeah theirs is a different thing at
least like here the government wasn't
trying to beat you up I mean just two
days ago Biden had to put a travel brand
ban to I don't want to get the country
wrong I think it might have been Kenya
because Kenya just like placed some like
death restrictions on anybody who these
don't like those YouTube videos you
watch when they're maybe it's Uganda I
don't want to say the wrong country yeah
it was Uganda
those videos are pretty funny when they
have like a whole seminar and it's like
made up stuff is that where the wire are
you gay video is that yeah what are you
getting what's this I guess yeah
again who who is gay you
yeah just the most base level in
communication I gotta show you this
video it's great if you watch the whole
video though it actually turns around oh
really a lot of people have seen because
the whole day is two hours oh wow you
find out that the accusers game though
well what happens yeah a pastor ends up
calling in to like berate the uh or the
trans host yeah or the trans guest and
then that Pastor drives to the radio
station and then shows up what a basket
full of fruits yeah and just like
insulting insulting them like super hard
no he had a basket full of vegetables
and gives examples of how they penetrate
each other in the butt with different
incredible but then that same host who
was saying why are you gay ends up
defending Pepe on Zimmer against that
Pastor
yeah yeah it's a it's a Tran well it's a
gay it's an lgbtq like uh activist and
she's being interviewed by the by the
News host or or the journalist and then
or like no he so so so he was called uh
the host was calling uh Pepe gay and
then paper was like I'm straight because
I identify as a man and then that's
where the the that's where he goes what
are you gay that's where it came and
that's the viral part but the whole
thing actually is really good
oh wait you mentioned in the previous
video you're like yeah when I was
growing up it was shunned couldn't be
gay because your parents how did they
take to you being like yo I'm gay uh I
didn't come out to them until I was 21
years old
uh so
honestly I think the YouTube videos I
was making was actually way more of like
a shock for them because of like I said
I did kind of like my humor was kind of
JK like adjacent like I crossed all the
lines pretty much because okay I think I
told you this but one of my biggest
Inspirations for comedy growing up with
Shane Dawson oh no [__] yeah so who's
your buddy right that's fine yeah so
like pretty much imagine if Shane Dawson
he doesn't play games at all but imagine
if he made a gaming channel back in like
two oh yeah yeah yeah that's kind of
what my videos were forever that makes
sense now I get the hair thing too the
Old Shane here
the humor back then was just way
hardcore though as well it was across
the board it was freezer yeah
yeah especially the competition for
attention a lot of people were throwing
that out just to get eyes so your
parents were like more uh
like held back by your content yeah like
that was already like I so whenever kind
of interesting story I knew my parents
wouldn't like it so I kept it a secret
for the first like three years or so
yeah and I was making like a full-time
income off of it without telling them
while also having another full-time job
okay and they were like trying to
convince me to pick up another second
full-time job and I was like no I'm good
I'm good or whatever like one job is
like enough when I actually had I mean
when you're a full-time YouTuber by
yourself that's like two or three jobs
like by itself yeah so I was like you
know I'm good and they just would not
stop pestering me so I was like listen I
have this YouTube channel you're not
gonna like it but I have a YouTube
channel and making money from it and
they looked it up they like get the
video that they saw first was probably
one of the most inappropriate ones like
I think I made a joke about
using it as lube or something like that
and he was not happy about that you
watched it together at least I said
vaginas he didn't find out I was gay
then
at least he's [__] them
[Laughter]
way supposed to put your penis inside
not your [__] but I wish I knew the joke
remember it
it was it's kind of a multi-leveled oh
it's like a knock knock I was doing a
parody of a parody oh okay word yeah
literally like we like those yeah
explain the whole thing a bit too much
honestly but literally him discovering
that was terrible he told me to delete
my channel and everything and like it
was like very
bad and so I just had to like kind of
cut them off for a couple years and just
like completely like not associate for a
while while I gave them time to you know
process everything yeah because I mean
to find out that
like I had like 150 000 Subs on YouTube
at the time so I was literally like
doing a lot of like big things like
underneath their notes damn very a very
secretive yeah
very good at being and those videos are
you out
no I didn't come out like publicly into
the internet until
a few years ago okay nice yeah I kept it
a secret from the internet your parents
were just pissed that you were doing
tubes
but you're making two videos they didn't
even know about the gaming two videos I
didn't glorify God uh yeah I got it damn
you're pretty supposed to be really fun
to hang out with though they're more fun
now you know that's nice and they always
kind of like wearing their way just like
as long as you adhere to their rules
like most religious families yeah yeah
like the camping's fun but then the
Bible study during the camping I'd
rather shoot a squirrel with a slingshot
yeah it's like why you gotta kill such a
cool thing man if you're watching a
[__] Batman movie and like why isn't
this movie about God and it's like oh
it's just Batman come on it's like
where's the part when he starts to save
Souls yeah
he's saving cat moving from any
religious bullet hypocrisy right it's
all cherry picking it's all sure
whatever fits your own agenda it's
whatever fits your own personal
narrative it's also my personal
political beliefs as well thank you yeah
there you go a cherry pick I [__] I'm
a hypocrite I don't give a [__]
[Music]
laughs